the [ __ ] is this
I don't like this oh wait we're playing
one of these maps
yeah with a Peterbilt chases us oh are
you kidding me go huh what I never
played any of these all right fell
through the mat this is my favorite map
wait I haven't even seen him yet you see
really there Oh God there he is oh good
no oh you missed me no never back huh
yes I never made it this far
nah [ __ ] he got my ass go go go go go go
go go go Oh ah yes yes let's go okay
let's go come on guys ped bear into like
bold science men [ __ ] my salad but I
think we should all just change
characters to little kids I feel like
that's more appropriate go go go go
we're all gonna make it
ah I got a head start
he's gonna take me guys [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate
this game what do you do
we've got plenty more things to get okay
time
can we change our chat itself to kids
let's download some kid the kid might oh
god it's the creepy one we've got a
better chance of surviving yeah it's
like Last Man Standing
yes okay okay oh god it's terrifying
especially this music I lost him a
lesson running just Hebron oh damn maze
is huge I got a dead end where's oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ah I got molested
Oh corner creeping this corner creeping
run
they're after so keep running keep
running I'm sorry
way out of this maze there is no way
let's hide he's not gonna make it in
here no way I'll cry in this corner you
cry in that corner I don't ruin the
defense I'm sorry I'm sorry I was just
checking the defense should we run
around with barrels yes I'm using them
as protection oh okay you go and check
if that guy's I'm done with this okay
okay let's escape the tiniest map ever
crazy
this is that this is minecraft that's
not you wanted it this is what he wanted
all along
no don't bring them here very simili
enough that Mia you Felix now I can
molest you I'm sure you can get up on
the tree which corner
I hear guys tell the king jelly weirdest
game mode
it's a go for me oh no no no you name
them you
combine them combine them combine them
combine them
now
gosh dang